[Music]
joining me today is an author the
editorial director of the American
Institute for Economic Research as well
as a senior fellow at the Austrian
economic center Jeffrey Tucker welcome
to the Rubin report thanks for having me
good to be here I almost wore the same
bowtie my friend really I should have
brought one extra for you yeah that
would have been work on this all right
there's a ton I want to talk to ya
you're sort of one of these people that
are right around all of the topics that
I'm talking about from freedom and
liberty and free speech and the battle
between the left and the right and all
that but your new book and I want to get
the title absolutely correct right wing
collectivism the other threat to Liberty
I thought that would be the spot for us
to kick this off because most of the
people watching the show know that I've
mostly focused on the left sure yeah was
my home I was a progressive I've woken
up to what I shouldn't real liberalism
is obviously and that has nothing to do
with the modern life but sometimes
people say Dave you don't critique the
right enough so let's dive in what's
interesting about talk about it is that
so often the left and the right are not
as distinguishable as they seem to be
for example the this trade stuff you
know Elizabeth Warren and Donald Trump
basically agreed yeah you know how do
you account for that and and now will
you see all the celebration of the
working classes you know you're gonna
get again the trumpian right agreeing
with Bernie Sanders on that the left is
evermore trending nationalist and it's
immigration policies for example that
didn't use to be the case so how is the
left well you know listen well like
Bernie Sanders complained that free free
immigration is is a coke a Koch
Industries plot basically to provide the
capitalist class cheap workers for
example now that you would have never
found anybody on the Left 20 years ago
saying that but but now you know it's
happening you know the the the the the
hatred of the of Commerce and and the
the merchant class is so intense now
that if a luxury resort and
in Florida wants to hire soon some
immigrants to work for them then the
left is saying oh no this is this is
terrible because this cab this
capitalism at work so here's trying to
see the strange blending the left and
the right have different cultural
pitches different appeals different
constituencies but they both have this
this agenda that's that boils down to
the to the use of power is this a little
bit of just what people refer to as the
horseshoe theory that the more that the
sides have become sort of extreme that
they're oddly that may be right I've
heard this this horseshoe thing I tend
to think that's a little bit superficial
I mean I look at it a little bit more
historically and you see since since
liberalism was born in the world in the
18th century really light Middle Ages
but when the revolt against liberalism
began in the early 19th century right
too much change too much wealth the
wrong people are getting rich there's
not enough control what are we going to
do about our religion our language our
race you know this the revolt began to
grow from about the 1820s and and
intensified and spread to the United
States Britain really began to take root
in continental Europe there took two
forms there was a left form and a right
form and at each country they took they
took on different iterations different
names you know so so in Britain you had
the Tories then you had the labor labor
party they both wanted to use the state
for their own purposes then you always
had the opposition party which is the
Liberals you know and and that's the way
it's fleshed out itself in country after
country the Liberal Party has always
been the people said why don't we just
let society be let people live their
lives let them choose a religion of
their own of their own choice if they
don't hurt anybody it's not a problem
let's have free speech this have
universal rights that's how rights for
this get rid of slavery let's have
rights acknowledge the existence of
women's rights equality of freedom for
everybody leave everybody alone
that's the liberal position that's a
pretty good position it's a it's a
beautiful position and it's what I
favorites what I think it's what built
civilization coming out of the religious
wars of the high middle ages we
discovered this idea of freedom we tried
it it worked
but there's but there's a brief there's
always been a revolt brewing against it
a resentment resentment against it again
resentment against the commercial class
too much change too much wealth wrong
people getting wealthy we're not
controlling demographics well enough
there's not enough equality whatever the
thing is it takes different forms in
different countries and at different
times in different places but ultimately
the right and the left are ideologies of
control and power and liberalism has
always been the alternative to that so
so we keep having to rediscover this
again and again in every generation yeah
well that's why now I'm so happy that
there is as you said to me right before
we started the phrase classical
liberalism now is coming back you know
you mean you had it on TV every now and
again I like to think that maybe I had a
little something to do with it you know
and meaning to me
it is the only current antidote to the
problems that we have either the the
more state power that the Democratic
socialists want as they've sort of
ransacked their own party and purged all
of the Liberals and it's also the
antidote for all of the people if you
think Trump is all of the horrible
things that people say about him all
time what's the antidote
the antidote isn't to get somebody else
in that more power yeah the antidote
obviously is to take power away from
that that's what liberalism and I my
hope is that that there are the good
people who left the center of the left
that are looking at the emergence of the
Trump problem will reconsider the uses
of power and the executive state and why
do we build this gigantic machinery of
the total state if it's so vulnerable to
being captured by our enemies right
right the real question that we're at
right now if you believe this thing has
been captured by the Russians or
whatever it is it's like yeah well okay
yeah and answering your own question I
hope that we can we can rekindle a kind
of a new resurgence or I do have to
credit you and Jordan Peterson for this
I mean I've been working at it for about
ten years to try to bring back this not
just the term liberal but the concept of
the brill ism
- to public life and but it's been
difficult because because because we do
have this state that creates a kind of
moral and intellectual and ideological
hazard
somebody's got to control it and and now
that we built it over the last hundred
years this this this total state of
massive taxes regulations interventions
run in people's lives everybody's trying
to get hold of it and grab it and beat
up their enemies and it's a problem it's
a serious problem so when people say to
me and we've discussed this on the show
a bunch of times before and I've dressed
address this in several forums when
people say to me wait a minute when
you're when you say you're a classical
liberal you talk about lazy for
economics and getting the government out
of the way and all those things really
this is just a repackaged libertarianism
or you're just afraid to say that you're
a conservative because it's still not
cool
or something that is how would you
define the difference between say
classical liberal and a libertarian
let's talk about that because because
after World War two these neologisms
these new terms came along one was
conservatism it wasn't really used
before the early 1950s Russell Kirk's
book called the mindset of a
conservative something like the
conservative mind I think is what it was
called and libertarianism was again
first used at about 1957 by the
translator of the works of Basquiat the
problem was the term liberal had been
captured you know by the new dealers
mmm-hmm as early as 1933 once they
acquiesced to the idea of the corporate
of a state andr blame the Great
Depression on capitalism that became a
problem for liberalism that kept the
term liberalism but they were no longer
liberal because they were suddenly for
big government here before big
government and and even worse the
corporate state and actually we can just
be more blunt about it and say that back
in the 1930s is this this ideology had a
name the name is fascist yeah okay so so
they caved right I mean in the New York
Times in 1933 the New York Times
magazine was celebrating the great
professor Mussolini
and how he and FDR shared a vision for
the planned economy so that's the world
we were living in back then so we lost
the term liberal after World War 2 there
was an attempt to to just speak language
and to and to describe who we are and on
one hand you had this new thing called
conservatism and they they they kind of
sampled some of the story
Tory like nostalgia for the past a
little bit of revanche ISM you know
let's recapture what we've lost didn't
you on the other hand who had the
genuine liberals and they coined the
term libertarianism which had been
sitting on the shelf since the late 19th
century now most of the people who call
themselves libertarians in the late 19th
century America and England were
anarchists socialists but nobody had
bothered with the term for decades and
decades
so Dean Russell said well nobody's using
that word why don't we use it and that
was closer to the truth of what they
were in effect well what was interesting
about that is as Dean Russell described
it in his 1957 article it was a synonym
for what was once called liberal right
he didn't think it was a tweak or an
improvement or a distillation or
refinement or a new dogmatic way of
describing the bill ISM he thought it
was liberalism so I need to read that
because I mean that's how I feel I don't
know if someone says me Dave you're a
libertarian I don't mind that if we need
labels I don't mind that lame I don't
mind you know we can split the
difference on how much government sure
should be so the problem I think
libertarianism has a number as a term as
the other problems one is it's a little
clinical sounding and it has too many
syllables and it makes you sound a
little bit awkward and it sounds maybe a
little too canonical you know like we we
have a list of things you have to
believe you know like this this this
it's all rooted in this kind of
reductionist more commonly these days
that's rooted in this kind of in the
reductionist non-aggression principle
which is a fine principle as a rule of
thumb but it's not a good it doesn't
describe the whole of life so the other
problem is that libertarianism is is a
new term so it doesn't have a deep
history so we can't look back
and say oh look the libertarians freed
the slaves the libertarians acknowledge
to the rights of women the the
libertarians gave us the commercial
society that built the middle class and
brought dignity to the average person
right if they had existed as a party
they would have done those they would
have done those yeah where's the
Liberals who did that but it delivers so
we changed our name so now we can't like
feel a sense of pride in our past so it
doesn't have a past hmm that's a problem
so we're libertarians tend to be
detached from their own history for that
reason and I think it's a it's a problem
as a word problem the second problems
that libertarianism doesn't have a
universal of usage like where's
liberalism does you can go to Spain
describe yourself in liberal Brazil
there's there's liberals in Germany
there's liberals Everett there's a word
for liberalism in every language and it
more or less means the same thing except
in the United States right so so if we
acquiesce to this term libertarian and
just wipe out our liberal history we're
cutting ourselves off both from the
world and from our own history it's so
funny because you've just said it in a
far better way than I think I've ever
really laid it out but people will say
to me Dave stop saying you're a liberal
and I don't want to stop saying them I
get that I'm fighting an uphill battle
right now right I'm a salmon swimming
upstream this is gonna be tough but I
don't want to deny what is the truth
just because because it's tough it's who
you are
and you want to you want to have it an
ancestry you know you want to look back
and and see the the champions of the
meta cheese and and 15th century
Florence and say I know those people
those are my people yeah you know the
people who long for a world without
slavery you know in the early 19th
century the people who wanted world free
trade and fought hard for it those are
our people that's our history I mean we
were we were born as part of a long
stream of emancipation that's been
taking place for 500 years that's our
movement our people our history let's
embrace it I'm with you brother yeah all
right so are there any of those
liberals part of the Democratic Party
anymore
do those people exist that's strange
things are happening on the left very
strange things and I I'm not sure I
should applaud you for one sec I have my
original question here was I wanted to
do the deep dive on the right so we're
gonna go we will get no I promise you
we're gonna get to them yeah the deep
dive on the far right gets us into a
very dark place yeah all right well
maybe that night so maybe the whole
second half will be on that let me just
put that out there right now that's what
we'll do really sighs it's not getting
out of my depression having my book it
was terrible all right so our whole
second half is gonna be what my first
question was about let's just keep going
on yeah out for now so so strange things
have happened to the left let's just
mention that the the phrase cultural
appropriation for example now when when
did that the approbation of the Society
of cultural appropriation came out over
what two three years ago you know four
five I don't know academia is weird it
may have been brewing for ten years yeah
but when I first heard about it I
thought that is the craziest bunch of
nonsense I've ever heard I mean
civilization is nothing but cultural
appropriation has been doing this since
since the 9th century you know at the
height of the comfo Vincey omits in
Spain where different Judaism and Islam
and Christianity came together in this
beautiful melting pot where we all learn
from each other and the cultures began
to blend and our religions began to
change in our our outlook on life began
to because we learn from each other if
we stay isolated in our little tribes
we're never gonna progress and and and
the idea that and I don't know if it was
inadvertent or what happened we can talk
about this but that when when suddenly
you're told you cannot have affection
for another culture and take what you
find valuable and and learn learn for
yourself and live a better life that is
very strange they seem to think it's
cultural annihilation not cultural
appropriation right like they seem to
know that this is something that will
lead to the destruction of that culture
when in fact yeah it actually spreads
the ideas of the culture the foods that
were losing the the ideas not just
they're generating culture
as a scarce good like it's a property
but it's not the magic of culture which
is the same magic of ideas is resides in
its infinite reproducibility and its
malleability this is something that the
world of ideas can do that the physical
world cannot do and if we don't make
that distinction we're gonna get very
confused do you see what I mean and
cultures spread and they're infinite and
they can constantly change and that's
the magic and beauty of culture we can't
get that out of this glass of water this
table right there they're bound by the
constraints of scarcity but the world of
ideas is as magical it's like a constant
constant infinite sandstorm you know
unpredictable and and constantly
changing and we can we can take a
culture for ourselves without taking it
from somebody else right it's just it's
it's it's reproductive reproduction it's
infinite reproduction so loaves and the
fishes
isn't isn't the beauty to that America
has done this better than anyone
perhaps in the history of the world you
just references some other points in
time but that we have taken in more
cultures and you said the phrase melting
pot I mean that that's what we designed
and set up here the most beautiful
melting pot ever I lived in New York
City for most of my life most of my
adult life at least and would be on
subway cars and you are on that car
with absolutely everyone with I have
white guys with dreadlocks and the whole
thing and guess what you may not like
everybody and you may not like the way
this guy smells and that person may be
doing this but we're all there and I
live in together it's magic you know
it's it's it really it's commerce it's
because this country elevated the
commercial ethos to be the the highest
thing the great ennobling factor of
human life and its commerce that brings
people together and we experience that
every day you know you can in a
commercial setting people aren't
fighting each other they're they're
getting along I mean I I find I'm with
you I go to that I go to a restaurant
and I get served by some guy from
from Pakistan it's it it's a chance to
meet somebody new it's a chance to
engage somebody to have a personal
relationship with somebody who's serving
you and you're serving them and you
experience this magic of exchange
Benjamin constant used to talk about
this and the 1830's how how how commerce
brought to the world a new understanding
of freedom and a new opportunity for us
to find value in each other in service
of each other and can America just
flourished in commerce and that's why
that's why we have you know the the
diversity and this melting pot you call
it and this rich cultural life you know
it's so funny because I'm so keenly
aware of it right now not only because
of the conversations I'm having and
because people are screaming about this
stuff all the time but you know I'm on
this tour with Jordan Pederson and when
I go to every airport that I go to a 90
percent of the time unless someone said
a car for me I take an uber and it's hop
in whatever rubra shows and there is
there there is every single type of
person that looks every which way and
every little or every sexuality and
usually I talk a little bit to them it
you know and it's like man these are
just people I've you know I'm maybe for
the same way you know I live in Atlanta
which is just a gigantically diverse
society you know and everywhere you go
you're bumping into people who are
different from you and and hang around
in crypto circles in Atlanta I want to
yeah yeah and and that you talk about a
melting pot I mean we're all together
and there we all consider each other our
people you know just because we all love
crypto today and it has nothing to do
with with race you can appreciate racial
differences with but also see value in
everybody and and hope they can see
value in you you can come together it
doesn't mean that we have to be
egalitarian or deny differences it means
that we find strength in our
heterogeneity and and that's that makes
for a beautiful and exciting life one of
the strangest things is happening now
you know with the rise of the alt-right
in response to the failures and and
strangeness of the left is this new
celebration of homogeneity
we need to live in a unitary racial
state you know where we all speak the
same language or all of the same
religion so that strikes me as
aesthetically very boring and I don't I
don't even recognize what that world
would look like and feel like and it
doesn't appeal to me in the slightest
bit yeah Minerva it was built out of the
out of the diversity that grows out of
Commerce and the commerce is the key
because that's what helps us invest in
each other you know Adam Smith said this
about the division of labor right it's
like what causes wealth the division of
labor how big can that be it should be
as big as possible the wider the
division of labor the more people you
include in the great project of a
building commercial life and production
the wealthier we're all going to be
together and I just I love that vision
so when we talk about capitalism others
show I'll every now and again I jump in
the comment section or I see what people
say on Twitter if I have you know some
of the Iran people on or just some of
the people that are not for a regulation
oh and just let the economy go and see
what happens there's always a certain
amount of people that say okay that all
sounds well and good but then the rich
just keep getting richer and the poor
keep getting poorer and Jeff Bezos
shouldn't have you know 20 trillion
dollars or whatever he has right now or
the rest of it what's the what's the
boilerplate answer to why he ventured it
over those kind of cliches because I've
been they've been around for 150 years
and they're never untrue
I mean that would they weren't true and
Marx this time and everybody you know
quickly recognized that you know by the
late 19th century in America we had we
had built the most prosperous economy in
the world by far by far by far growing
incomes longer lives healthier people
more opportunities for everybody people
are moving to the cities everybody's
benefiting from capitalism that's been
going on for such a long time again here
we are in 2018 and we're still recycling
these this Victorian era
it's about capitalism I don't understand
it what do you think capitalism then
screwed up if if only just a marketing
piece of it or something where right now
you sense and I believe that it will not
win it that it somehow doesn't seem cool
to be for capitalism at least with you
to be the change maybe it's in the name
and I did I don't even have a problem
not using them the word capitalism I
mean I would probably have the same view
towards this I will speak the language
that that you can understand and if I
want to rebrand capitalism as liberalism
which it probably should be actually
liberal liberalism then I'm glad to talk
about that the same time I kind of like
the term capitalism I have no problem
with it because because it really does
underscore a really important point that
without private-property in the in the
end ownership of the means of production
you can't have a complex production
structures and you can't hire more
people you can't you can't build great
things you can't have great cities you
can't improve people's lives so what are
the things that you think government
should do well I think of lots of
cleansing rules that we should have but
I'm not a fan of governments in general
if there was some way that you could
have you know an old-fashioned liberal
state you know that was really minded
his own business and kept kept civil war
from happening for example you know kept
conflict that kind of mass conflict then
that would be a probably a good good
thing state is not very good at that so
I think I mean I've got I've got the
mind of an anarchist essentially I trust
you know I trust the chaos of of
spontaneous human action much more than
any kind of imposition yeah but but I am
at the same time I do like the writings
of the old liberals you know they they
imagine that the state should do
something to keep something like a order
in life to keep civil war from happening
to keep people from killing each other
terrible things like that but beyond
that state should just it should be less
a fair I should just allow commerce to
flourish and allow law problems to work
themselves out I and people don't have
confidence in that anymore
but not because of any failure but it's
almost like the ideology of power has
become a kind of a modern
cancer that affects afflicts everyone
and I think we need to do something
about it
wait can you explain that a little bit
well it's just a once you believe that
you can control the path of history and
you have an endpoint in mind society
should look like this then you want to
use every kind of tool to hammer it in
place and this is this is what I call
right and left wing Hegelian ISM
essentially and it's it's a grave
temptation and so we built this like we
said at the outset and we built this
gigantic machinery we call the state
this total state and it controls so much
wealth and so much power and so much
rests with with getting you know gaining
access to it that it's just a kind of a
constant moral hazard for everybody like
give me that state and I'll make it do
the right things right so for the people
that on either side of this whether
you're on the left and you want to help
those that you deem oppressed more
people with less when I believe their
intentions to be good even if their
methodology I think generally is not
good or your people on the right that
want less of a state but you know you're
just on either side of this thing how
much do you think the the system itself
can move without breaking because what I
think I'm noticing now is that there's a
certain amount of people that really
just want to trash the whole thing and I
do see this certainly more on the left
right now because they're not in power
then there's this growing thing and this
is why they're so into Marxism and all
this stuff now it's like let's just
trash the whole freaking thing and
forget all the goodness that this is
done and they're doing it from their
iPhones and you know their sense of
irony is not great but if there is their
system you mean right now is there just
a certain amount that a system that's
basically good can move before it snaps
and I would suspect that it's not much
either way really you mean the the
commercial structure right now or our
lives our capitalist leaders we mean the
state you know what I see actually
happening is the innovation has taken
place so quickly it's actually
outrunning the the capacity of
government to control it and I think
that's that's really exciting if I was
gonna look at one point of hope in the
world is that the the market
the entrepreneurial innovative sectors
of life from the app economy to the gig
economy to now with with blockchain
technology and everything is moving so
quickly that states can't can't even
keep up all right so I'm there with you
on that because I Laureus I'm very happy
about that I see that because it's to me
it's like how are people listening to
all of these conversations all of these
podcasts that are out there and
communicating about them so quickly and
it's like the government can't know it
can't keep up with all of that the
change can't because people are lighting
up all the time now in a much faster way
and I think we're changing in a much
more rapid way and I think that's
actually really cool there's a danger to
it because we could just spin out of
control and do all sorts of awful things
but what you said well what did you say
before about the general inertia of
people or something that the general
left to their own ways of figuring
things out I'll figure it out and you
know there's a reason why our politics
seem reactionary on the left and the
right everyone's trying to bring back
something there's there's a nostalgia on
the left and a nostalgia on the right
and they're trying to use the state to
hold us back
like and and whatever it's a vision of
the is that the sixties is it is it the
seventies is it pre-industrial
revolution you know is that some reso
Ian fantasy and perfect equality in oh
that the left might imagine or or or the
right thinking about you know a world of
high tariffs of the 1880s or nineties or
but everyone's looking back to something
they want to create and it's there's a
real fear of the future on the left on
the right and it's a future without
control it's a future where we're able
to travel where we want to download the
apps we want to invent what we want to
work by ourselves live where we want to
live be digital nomads you know travel
around do it we want this this world
that's so cool that's not what people
should be fearing people everyone should
be going holy cow this is the freest
coolest thing ever that's the world I
want to live in that Matt obviously is
why you're so attracted to Bitcoin also
right and crypto general sure which is
sort of the the backbone
I mean if you think about it I mean
we've waited our whole lives and
actually generations of great
intellectuals have lived lived and died
for so long
wanting something like a private
currency that that emerged privately
that operates without financial
intermediaries that the government is
not controlling that's global that
doesn't it's not restrained by currency
zones that anyone could have access to
you know a true democratic technology
like Bitcoin or any cryptocurrency that
is just a dream come true
that is glorious that's why I write
about it all the time and talk about it
all the time
it is it is the alt-right killer it is
the alt left killer it's it's the thing
that's going to ultimately I think
protect us from these wicked ideologies
that are constantly trying to control
their lives because basically at some
point one of these ideologies is going
to get too much control of the state
just fine each other forever I mean you
know one of the things that I think
about this sometimes when you get
depressed about the divisions in our
public life and the way people are
tearing you're tearing each other apart
and the way you open up the newspaper in
the city you can barely even read it
anymore yeah you know it was like yeah I
know I know but it's like down the Trump
you know then just like a know up with
Trump you know and it's just it's just
this forever debate and the one thing
that I think maybe we should not be
entirely unhappy about this is you look
back at history when when freedom
emerges out of the high middle ages it
wasn't because any one great
intellectual or any one great state or
any one great power said hey let's let
everybody be free it was because there's
so many competitors for power that they
nobody could could gain the monopoly it
was the church it was the the
nation-state it was the the locality of
some monarchical state that the landed
aristocracy you know the the rising
merchant class you know so they're all
these independent power centers strewn
throughout European society and nobody
can get get access to the final single
singular control no unitary power and so
that fight that took place among so many
disparate powers actually led to a kind
of flourishing of freedom so you know
in a sense the fight between the left
and the right today is not the worst
thing if they just keep fighting and
leave the rest of us alone that lucky
but okay so before we spend the whole
second half on the question that I
started this whole thing with the people
who want freedom basically and a light
touch of government are they always at a
disadvantage because there's another set
of people who will always use the
apparatus against them where if they're
being true to themselves they won't use
the power to stifle other people or all
sorts of other things so in an odd way
our ideas are at a dissident always have
been we've always been a kind of
minority so even again over the last two
three hundred years of political history
we've always been that that third way
that's my minority but we had we had
rare victories but big ones you know
like the end of slavery you know was
just glorious I mean the protection of
the great banking empires of Europe from
from the populist rabble you know from
the from the preachers who wanted to
destroy it there were these great
victories the victory of free trade you
know but but we've won every one swell
and it always changed the world because
once you have a little bit of freedom
just a little bit it just blows up and
it becomes awesome and it's amazing it
and it and it kills power because it's
so powerful and so wonderful but it's
worth fighting for and we've always
fought mainly through ideas not through
armies not through through guns and
controlling States has always been the
philosophical awesomeness of this
position has been the celebration of the
common man the celebration of wealth the
the love of consumerism and commercial
life or the coming together of people
the noble meant of people that the the
right of travel the right of association
and to do what you want to have as many
children as you want to to educate your
kids the way you want to that these
kinds of principles are compelling and
they've always led to victory for
liberals despite the pressure from the
other two sides and I think that's I
think it's gonna be our future I do
[Music]
you